there's been theories that enchantress
is actually the villain of the movie so
now I need you to when you know through
this looking through this through the
looking glass with me here you won't see
June moon working you know in hero shots
you won't see transfers working with
everybody else el Diablo here of course
making fire out of his hand so he's a
Pyromancer right there here's what I
want you to know about suicide squad
based on this trailer based on what i
think i think that Suicide Squad is
going to be as they are now expanding
the Cinematic Universe for the DC this
will be the first movie where they
really introduce magic its lift not for
sure the theory on the internet was like
we've never seen him in marketing
materials really we don't see many of
the hero shots he must die in a scene
like this I think these are all
flashbacks and that's where I think it
comes down to that we open and we're
gonna open this movie with Harley being
dr. Quinzel she's working in Arkham or
whatever and then both doors explode
Joker's dudes come in down and I'm gonna
hurt you real bad and it's hard cut and
we jump weeks months ahead or whatever
to where we'll see it later where she
was doing that sexy dance yeah all or
whatever she got like the gold on do I
think this is the case under no
circumstance but I would say and I don't
think it's gonna happen so don't yell at
me when it's not cuz I know it's not I'm
getting from this view a bit of a
brainiac vibe do I think brainiacs
getting introduced in Suicide Squad and
the suicides got no not at all but
there's a little bit of rain going on
here if I'm being honest you know you
could be like a setup for something
exactly the infection that's on earth
could that could be the thing but then I
don't say nutrient enchantresses
involvement speaking of there she is
rolling her eyes of a theory no that's
not Brainiac Greg you're so cute and
handsome everyone should value on
Twitter all right